let's see who else is on the phone six
to six let's go to the six to six area
code who's calling from six to six today
hi Dave
my name is Michelle Lopez from LA and my
question is should we you know should we
even care should we even try to do
anything about the DNC as in putting so
much resources towards it to change it
my brain is doing at the moment or
should we just go third party listen
right now
the DNC at the federal level is the
possible path to the progressive ization
of American politics I wish that weren't
the case but right now it's gonna be
very difficult to say the future of
progressivism and the immediate is
through third parties so I take an
all-of-the-above approach I think it's
important as I've said before not to
support third parties just because they
are third parties if they have wacky and
crazy ideas but right now
between how elections are financed and
the fact that we don't have some kind of
ranked choice or multiple selection
model it is going to be really difficult
for third parties to make any real
progressive headway so I think that
right now reforming the DNC is a good
effort and I would also add if you
reformed the DNC successfully such that
it actually bolsters the progressive
movement that will bolster third parties
in the long run as well part of the
reason why right now the third party
sort of world is not flourishing is that
you have both parties Democrats and
Republicans that are just kind of like
so far from being aligned with the
actual desires of so many voters that
the existence of the DNC doesn't really
foment support for third parties in any
way if the DNC moves to the left you
might actually see at the state level at
the local level we're seeing a little
bit but maybe even at the state level
some more fluidity between Democrat and
third party and and some possibilities
there so I think that the reform of the
DNC is a very worthwhile way to go but I
share your concern that in the long run
the Democratic Party going to be the
bastion of progressivism that's probably
an unreasonable expectation I think
right now we have to use it to keep
moving to the left and hopefully
eventually really shake up the system
we've got yeah it's just I'm just trying
to voice my concern because we have
quote/unquote progressive endorsing you
know like Cuomo yeah so he's not really
a progressive take your so yeah we have
progressives we have actual progressives
endorsing Cuomo yeah Cortes she it was
on I forgot a I think of seeing CNN or
something like that she ended up
actually endorsing him right and rather
than a more progressive candidate you
know yeah yeah I mean that's a kind of a
specific case which maybe maybe we'll
talk about individually I share your
concern Miguel really appreciate the
call I do have to go but thank you so
much for calling in on that note we will
have to go to a break sorry to everybody
that we didn't get to but we will take
calls again